[Musica]
allora io vedevo parlare di donne devo
dire che ne abbiamo uno a cui bellissima
che sta guardando il suo destino ora
parlando dvd donne devo parlarvi del 54
per cento della popolazione mondiale
quindi occhio e croce vi devo tenere qui
due tre settimane credo per riuscire
esaurire tutti gli argomenti perché
questo è un argomento che abbraccia
veramente tutto il nostro mondo
pensiamo alla violenza che c'è quel
titolo
l'ho ammazzata perché l'amavo troppo e
qui la stampa i giornalisti hanno una
bella responsabilità in come raccontano
questi fatti oppure pensiamo a tutti i
paesi del mondo in cui non c'è nessuna
libertà per le donne più però mi occupo
di economia e quindi devo parlare di
quello che è l'impatto della mancata
parità nel mondo della dell'economia e
del lavoro
allora io ho pensato di raccontarvelo
raccontandovi un pochino di me ma dovete
sapere che io fin da bambina ho avuto
una convenzione molto forte quella di
essere una femmina prevede certo mi
chiamo silvia bambina portavo i codini
le gonnelle perché ma quando si ero
bambina io si usavano le gonnelle per le
bambine pantaloni solo per andare in
montagna
poi sono andata adolescente sono
scoperti ragazzi quindi c'erano i
corteggiamenti i trucchi e le minigonne
perché l'era di toccare le minigonne
tutto questo rigorosamente uscendo da
casa perché in casa mia non è che
avessimo questa grande libertà però se
c'erano delle limitazioni queste
limitazioni erano per noi figlie femmine
ma anche per l'unico figlio maschio che
avevano i miei genitori
avevamo il coprifuoco a mezzanotte pure
lui facevamo i turni per lavare i piatti
pure lui dovevamo aspettare la nostra
stanza pure lui anzi devo dire che lui
essendo forza del segno della vergine e
molto più ordinato di me poi è arrivato
il mondo del lavoro e io sono le cose
pre voluto fare la giornalista
ci ho messo un pochino effettivamente a
diventare giornalista
ma ci ho pensato dopo del perché questo
mi era stato così complesso e difficile
da ottenere ma mi dici mi piaceva
moltissimo mi piaceva soprattutto fare
le notti al giornale quando si faceva la
ribattuta fino all'ultimo momento e se
usciva le 4 5 di mattina con il giornale
fresco in mano era proprio l'idea di
partecipare alla vita che si stava
vivendo costruendo
poi a un certo punto ho finalmente
aspettato un bambino era notizia
bellissima ma è stato in quel momento
che io ho fatto una scoperta che per me
è stata sconvolgente perché vi ho detto
che io ho sempre pensato di essere una
femmina una donna
io in quel momento ho capito che era una
donna è certo dicevo a me da dove
nascano dalle femmine almeno fino adesso
ma il re ma non era questo qui era che
mentre io la mia pancia cresceva altri
pensavano che il mio cervello diminuisce
io non so bene esattamente come mai sia
successa questa cosa però come dire e lo
stato una brillante studentessa
all'università allora liceo e
all'università con correvo col mio amico
giorgio per avere migliori voti di
scuola scuola e purtroppo siamo usciti
con lo stesso identico voto
e questo un pochino mi pesa anche se se
lo meritava ecco quella brillante
studentessa e la solida giornalista che
ero diventata erano più la stessa cosa
era diventata un po inattendibile un
pochino che stupida un ostacolo ecco
definirei esattamente che lo diventato
un ostacolo
ora questa era la prova provata che io
ero una donna perché queste cose
succedono soltanto le donne non
succedono gli uomini e vi sono anche
accorta che lo stato anche un pochino
ceca in effetti perché pensando che le
donne fossero donne come gli uomini e
gli uomini ciascuno quello che gli pare
di essere io non è che mi fossi posta
tante domande quando ai colloqui di
lavoro mi dicevano ma lui vorrebbe avere
dei figli ed io bella felice ma certo
dove la verde figli mia con da una
famiglia perciò siamo in quattro e tutti
facevano tutto figuriamoci sono voglio
avere dei figli
ma questa domanda non la facevano amica
gli uomini e non mi ero neanche tanto
interrogata sul fatto di come sarebbe
appunto stato considerato il mio buon
vedersi qui assicuro molto buono
quoziente intellettivo
se io fossi stata un uomo che stava per
diventare padre
il mio paziente intellettivo sarebbe
rimasto come su come minimo uguale ma
altrimenti sarebbe stato valorizzato per
un motivo semplice perché le mie
responsabilità di uomo diventavano
maggiori diventavo padre di famiglia
allora gli ho detto che mi ha fatto
capire che io sono non tanto ordinata a
casa però sono molto come si dice molto
determinata e quindi ho cominciato a
studiare ho cominciato a studiare anche
a ripensare delle frasi e delle cose che
io non avevo mica ascoltato per esempio
non avevo ascoltato la mia cara amica
del cuore quando dopo un colloquio di
lavoro era uscita e mi aveva detto sai
ma l'ho detto di fronte a te che sei una
donna io si trova un uomo con meta
competenze io sono l'uomo e avevano
assunto l'uomo ecco qui ci vorrebbe un
esclamazione come dire non propriamente
consona e quindi non la faccio però
studiando mi sono domandata ma tutte
queste studentesse che escono dalle
università perché non le vediamo nel
mondo del lavoro
per quale motivo noi non vediamo donne
ai vertici e per noi abbiamo appena
festeggiato festeggiato abbiamo appena
sottolineato in modo molto positivo il
fatto che le il tasso di occupazione
femminile l'italia si è arrivato al 48,8
per cento ma noi siamo penultimi in
europa dopo la grecia e prima di malta è
ancora qui a cortina siamo cortina e
quindi questo è un tema che si capisce
quando si parla di nomine pubbliche voi
sapete che si scatena una bagarre
nei giornali ma soprattutto nei luoghi
di potere no parliamo delle né dell'eni
e di tutte queste società qui allora
dieci anni fa quando si scatenava quello
che viene chiamato il toto nomine di
nomi femminili non ce n'era neanche uno
questo ve lo assicuro ma non per fare
l'amministratore delegato che tanto non
c'è neanche adesso
ma neanche per entrare nel consiglio di
amministrazione nel 2007 e le donne nei
consigli di amministrazione erano solo
il 5 per cento e fu calcolato a quello
in quel periodo che sarebbero serviti
costant anni per arrivare ad avere il 30
per cento
come si chiama questo monopolio e cosa
succede ai monopoli monopoli si
abbattono e quindi è stata fatta sotto
altra parte è stato abbattuto il
monopolio dell'energia a quello della
della telefonia no quindi si è abbattuto
un monopolio con una legge che ha
previsto di ma di avere un tetto del 30
per cento per il genere meno
rappresentato questa una legge che andrà
conclusione perché una legge momentanea
ora il tema è capire perché però noi ci
troviamo in questa situazione noi
sappiamo che siamo in buona parte di
quello che siamo dipende da come siamo
formati nei primi anni della nostra vita
quindi dalla famiglia e dalla scuola io
per questo e vi ho citato prima
la mia famiglia dove le regole erano
uguali per tutte nel padre lavorava
all'estero ha lavorato molto spesso
all'estero quando veniva in italia il
fine settimana cucinava la scuola la
scuola noi abbiamo ancora dei libri di
testo in cui i ball e bambine hanno due
manciate non di più di modelli cioè un
modello della maestra della mamma della
strega della matrigna
per fortuna c'è astros a malta adesso
vorrei dire ma ci ha salvato tantissimo
a sosa ma associa malta i bambini invece
hanno molti modelli hanno i condottieri
gli scienziati hanno gli esploratori
anno quelle cose che li proiettano verso
il mondo
magari il giorno non sono
tanto contenti di essere spinti a essere
proiettati verso il mondo perché lo
stereotipo che poi è quella cosa che
appunto fa sì che tu debba essere quello
che gli altri si aspettano che tu sia no
non è mica detto che i bambini a seno
così e contente per cui tu noi tutti
pensiamo che un maschio gli piaccia
giocare a calcio e sono gli piace
giocare a calcio ci sarà qualcosa che
non funziona e se invece piace ha una
bambina ci sarà lo stesso qualcosa che
non funziona perché si dice che per le
bambine non piace giocare a calcio
allora io devo parlare di numeri e
quindi vedo qualcuno pochissimo e non ho
portato slide ne prendo i numeri ne
prendo uno da mckinsey mckinsey dice che
se ci fosse parità totale nel mondo tra
uomo e donna il pil del mondo sarebbe
più alto di 28 tiri triliardi di dollari
all'ora 28 triliardi di dollari è una di
quelle come dire cifre che io non so
immaginare mi viene in mente solo giu
paperone che conta tutti i suoi soldi in
questo suo grande deposito
l'altro dato che voglio citare e quello
che prende gli altri due titoli prende
dal world economic forum che ogni anno
fa uno studio su questi su questi temi
allora nell'ultimo rapporto cosa ha
detto ha detto che ci vogliono 100 96
anni per arrivare alla piena parità tra
uomini e donne
nessuno di noi qua la vedrà
poi ci dice che l'italia è al
cinquantesimo posto su 144 paesi ma è al
100 xvii per quello che riguarda
l'accesso al mondo del lavoro
quindi c'è qualcosa che non funziona e
che va corretto potremmo dire tante cose
perché ovviamente possiamo parlare di
leggi per esempio io sono
favorevolissimo al congedo obbligatorio
di paternità
sono favorevole modificare le leggi
sulla maternità che secondo me oggi sono
un freno in italia ci sono tantissimi
argomenti
però abbiamo dei tempi strettissimi io
lo vedo qua sono abituate quindi devo
restare in quel tempo lì e quindi vado
alle conclusioni e le mie conclusioni
sono due consigli 1 le ragazze alle
ragazze io dico di non abbandonare mai
mai mai mai mai ho detto
sufficientemente volte mai la propria
dipendenza economica perché non c'è
nessuna assicurazione che le può aiutare
di più
l'altra cosa la dico visto che ci sono
pochi imprenditori manager formatori lo
dico alle aziende le aziende devono
cambiare la loro modalità di
organizzazione del lavoro
c'è una disparità totale e vi posso
portare tutte le ricerche che volete
tra le aziende italiane e le aziende
estere non c'è proprio lo si vede a
occhio nudo c'è uno spartiacque le donne
le donne che entrano nel mondo
dell'azienda proprietà italiana hanno
possibilità di fare carriera pochissimo
le aziende che entra nelle
multinazionali ce ne hanno tantissimo e
il punto sta nella organizzazione del
lavoro e dei modelli di misurazione ora
però a noi siamo in un mondo
globalizzato
noi guardiamo su internet dove trovare
il vestito che costa meno e questo ha
messo in crisi tutte le aziende che si
occupano di retail e di tutte queste
cose qua ma metterà in crisi anche le
aziende perché andremo a vedere quali
sono le aziende che offrono le migliori
condizioni
e siccome abbiamo visto che abbiamo
tanti cervelli in fuga e non a caso
molte sono donne
magari andranno da un'altra parte grazie
[Applauso]